and The Wall Street Journal reports from
the Saints so file the largest toy store
chain in the US Toys R Us has filed for
bankruptcy protection the chapter 11
filing overnight is among the largest
ever by a specialty retailer now it
comes as Toys R Us is gearing up for the
holiday shopping season which accounts
for most of its sales CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
what this means for the future of the
retail giant Joe good morning I'm
thinking of Jeffrey the giraffe I'm
thinking of all the I want to be a toys
or as kids wonder how did this happen
you know it looks like competition
obviously we know that from Walmart
Target big boxes like that have really
eaten into the business also Amazon but
I should also note that this company was
taken private back in 2005 and it was
done and it went private with borrowed
money so the company has five billion
dollars of long-term debt no matter how
well you're doing that's an awfully big
load to carry what does it mean for the
stores and for the employees well there
are currently sixteen hundred stores and
it looks like some of the
underperforming stores will likely close
down during this restructuring process
but the CEO said hey we are open for the
holidays they didn't mention anything
about laying people off but they're
going to try to use this holiday season
and a restructuring of debt to try to
reinvigorate the brand okay
is this an example of private equity
going bad probably it may be one of
those in cases and we saw this back with
the Sears story now Sears is not
bankrupt but remember a similar story a
big private equity firm which is
essentially an amalgamation of wealthy
people who want to make an investment in
a company take that company borrow debt
to buy that company and then try to
operate the company now the problem is
that in doing so they have less money to
invest in the company itself right
because we're servicing debt so this is
a problem can I go to a problem we
discussed in a story earlier than the
story about Toys R Us which is the
Equifax situation sure what do people
who are worried that they have been
exposed do okay
so let's talk about this before okay so
we've done this before scan we do three
big pieces here go to export Equifax
security 2017 dot-com that is the
website you see whether or not you've
been compromised you then put a
free fraud alert on your credit file you
can do that with Equifax Experian or
TransUnion then the last step if you can
you may want to choose to freeze your
credit this will lock down your file
this also means that you yourself cannot
apply for new credit so if you're in the
process of maybe applying for student
loans FAFSA forms are available on
October 1st a car loan a mortgage don't
freeze your file but if you don't need
credit if you like your existing credit
keep what you have I just want to go to
toys or else go go go let's keep Jeffery
alive so I always like that store Thank
You Jill Thank You Jill